[Music]
from the writer directors who brought
you this movie and not much else
comes the game-changing horror film that
made back 20,000 percent of its budget
changed the face of the genre and pissed
off a generation of film school nerds
who wish they'd thought of it first The
Blair Witch Project before you watch the
top-secret sequel no one knew was coming
or asked for revisit the original whose
collection of scenes about a bunch of
kids wandering around the woods for 90
minutes cuz we're making a documentary
not about us getting lost making
documentary about a witch arguing about
a map give me the [ __ ] map I gave you
back the map Heather I gave you back the
math you're taking turns losing their
[ __ ] we had enough in the same place
there's no one here to help you that's
your fault and then dying in a shack I
think in a film that combines the
pulse-pounding excitement of backpacking
in Maryland with a breathtaking suspense
of amateur film production logistics how
we're gonna get the DAT across how are
we gonna get the DAT across back how are
we gonna get the DAT across no one cares
meet Heather Mike and Josh three kids
whose names you'll only remember because
they're constantly yelling them at each
other
Josh Mike josh mike josh Josh Josh Mike
Josh
Mike yeah
are you going around doing your
documentary thing man you stood watch as
they practically beg for death by
ignoring the warnings of locals I don't
go you don't go up there yeah I believe
enough not to go up there knocking over
rock totems
you didn't just knock that over please
tell me you didn't just knock they're
stealing food ooh dolls she left little
trinkets you don't one of them and going
into a creepy old murder house then
again the response to getting lost was
walking for 15 hours with heavy packs in
a random direction how to stay alive in
the woods because she never know it's
gonna happen they clearly did not read
that so suit off for the fake snuff film
that introduced the world to the
scariest monster of all viral internet
marketing as this fake film trick the
internet into thinking it's real actors
were missing or dead and tricked America
into believing something actually
happened in this movie leaving behind a
minefield of future viral marketing
campaigns this will be basically
invented catfishing good job so sorry
story rocks sticks a clanging noise more
rocks more sticks more clanging noises
shaky camera shots of the ground shaky
camera shots of the forest bad camera
work camping
crossing the streams a black screen
hello not showing you things the only
see you actually remember from the movie
and this guy's back that's it that's the
payoff man how are we so scared by this
thing Blaire a normal activity
[Music]
turn the camera off give me turn the
camera off and get us home stop taping
please stop laughing okay seriously
please stop filming is getting hard to
watch oh thank god hey screen junkies
Andy Daniel Spencer here with some
exciting screen junkies news yes we read
your comments dan tell him why yeah for
everybody calling us DC haters down
there in the comments
it's Marvel's turn because next Tuesday
September 13th the honest trailer for
Captain America Civil War drops right
here on screen junkies and we're not
taking any prisoners because our marvel
checks haven't cleared yet oh yeah yeah
speaking of checks check out this other
thing we did the roast of Captain
America it's coming out the same day as
the Civil War honest trailer and we are
gonna be brutal to Steve Rogers he's
getting roasted by all his friends from
Marvel and DC it's gonna be awesome
we're taking them down a peg and you can
check it out hopefully every month we'll
be doing pop-culture roasts on screen
donkeys Plus along with a brand new show
with Doug Benson that's right Doug loves
movies Doug Benson is doing a show
called pitch off it's so much fun you
can check out the first episode now so
please check it all out a plus and keep
staying tuned here let's turn around
Blair Witch style while Jon reads the
comments what do you mean they blew up
the Death Star what the hell is in
illumina Falken where's barb blips e
crinkle tasty goo we all like to poop in
our pant poop in our pants pube in out
pants
I'm nothing like the flash some might
even say I'm the reverse sassy pads